now at the beginning of this year i
didn't anticipate that i would end up
spending
you know a significant amount of time
discussing the bachelor on this program
the bachelor is
after all everything i hate about pop
culture condensed into one reality show
the bachelor's also everything i hate
about reality shows condensed into one
reality show
and it's still both of those things all
the more so recently but the racial
drama
surrounding the show in recent months is
so illustrative
and instructive that it's it's worth
paying attention to on those
grounds it's become a stage upon which
the macabre
pageantry of cancel culture has played
out
and all of the worst features of
canceled culture its cruelest
tendencies its most fraudulent aspects
as well
have been on full display so to briefly
review very briefly
before we get to the latest in this soap
opera rachel rachel kirk cannell was a
contestant on the bachelor she
eventually went on to win the show
which i think means that the bachelor
guy has to marry her or something i'm
still not clear on those details
but in any case it came out that rachel
three years ago at the age of 21
attended an old south themed frat party
there was nothing unusual about that at
the time those kinds of frat parties
were quite common
though probably not common anymore now
that it's clear that attending such a
party can ruin your life so probably we
won't be seeing those anymore
of course it was determined that the
only reason a college girl would go to a
frat party like that
is that she hates black people and so
she was condemned as a racist
i mean there's no other reason right no
one could conceive of any other reason
why somebody would have
went to that kind of party she
apologized repeatedly but that didn't
matter
um at all and then the former host of
the show chris harrison
initially defended rachel against the
canceled mob and was accused of racism
for defending her
and then he was promptly removed as host
and replaced with a black man named
emmanuel acho
who used to be a football player but now
makes his living as a race-baiting tv
personality
the bachelor himself matt james also a
black man and a former football player
uh turned businessman uh and so that
that about
sums it up i think that gets us up to
speed that's that's what's going on
there
rachel was canceled for going to a party
the host was canceled for defending the
girl who was canceled
and that brings us to the special that
aired on abc last night
it was decided that apparently this
whole issue with the frat party
had not been hashed out enough a
month-long news cycle
hundreds of news stories millions of
people denouncing her
repeated tearful apologies none of that
was enough
because nothing is ever enough they had
to bring rachel on the air again
to humiliate and degrade her some more
now rachel as far as i know was not
kidnapped and forced to take part
in this spectacle at gunpoint she
volunteered for it
for whatever reason perhaps still
believing in her hopeless naivete
that eventually if she apologizes enough
she'll be forgiven and allowed to just
move on with her life
what she doesn't realize didn't realize
still somehow does not realize
is that she can't be forgiven because
there's nothing to forgive
and the people she's asking for
forgiveness from were not harmed or
injured by her in any way so they can't
provide her with forgiveness
this is not about any alleged sin she
committed and never was
she's not a person okay she's not an
individual named rachel in the eyes of
the cancelled mob
she is rather a white woman or more to
the point
a representative of whiteness and her
job is to be chastised and humiliated
and they'll keep doing that to her as
long as she offers herself up to be the
ceremonial sacrifice so let's take a
look at how the ceremony played out last
night
rachel's brought on stage given yet
another opportunity to apologize
um somehow the apology needed to be
given specifically to matt
james who somehow has become the special
victim
of a party that rachel went to three
years ago before she knew him
now if it were me ask to apologize to
matt james over something like that
my apology would sound something like
this i would say hi matt james
i'm sorry that you're a huge baby please
get over yourself
and that would be it and if rachel had
said that
i would be ready to build a statue in
her honor
and defend it from the mobs that come to
tear it down but that is certainly not
what rachel said instead she said this
let's listen
i think that you know everything up to
this point i think that you know
exactly how i feel
i really just want to take the time to
say i'm really sorry
and once i really tried to
to put myself into your shoes as much as
i could
i really do think that
our relationship was very strong and the
love that we shared was very real
so for you to to end things
i
i realized that that must have been
really hard for you as well to wear
you must have been hurting and i just
wanted to say i'm really sorry for
not understanding that initially um
and that i'm really sorry that i hurt
you
the love that we shared was very real
yeah the love was as real as
anything else that's going on here and
all the other emotions on display as
real as that
it would be so uncomfortable for me to
be
matt james accepting this apology
from someone who didn't do anything to
me like it would be hard for me to do
and keep a straight face the entire time
i would have trouble doing that
but he is such a narcissist that he
actually thinks he deserves this apology
and so that's how he's able to to
stomach this and to keep a straight face
so was that enough had she finally
apologized enough not remotely
matt james a grown man was left tearful
and speechless
due to the trauma he suffered and is
still suffering from a picture of a 21
year old chick
at a frat party the host gave james some
time to collect himself
but you know he could he could barely
speak and he he tried to
he just was so overcome with emotion
because of this picture from a frat
party three years ago
uh he was trying to offer some kind of
response and this was all that he could
get out let's watch
matt how um how hard is this on you
just seeing the woman that you love
that you loved i'm so torn up
over hurting you and over losing you
um i mean
it's it's heartbreaking and it's
devastating
it's
it's just it's just disappointing
matt there's so much more on your heart
i don't even wanna
i don't even wanna interject i can see
it in your eyes
what else do you want to share with her
he can't get it out he just he can't
it's so difficult for him this is so
hard
this is so hard for matt james so how
hard is this for you matt james how hard
is it for you
that this woman's life is over and that
you helped make that happen
how hard is it for you that you that you
had to throw her under the bus was that
really hard for you
that bus was coming and and you you you
had to make the choice to pick her up
and chuck her right under it
right so the wheel just went right over
her skull that had to be
is that hard for you must've been so
hard so so hard
if you didn't know the context you might
think that rachel had shot matt's dog
or burned his house down or at least
victimized him personally in some way
and in fact even if she had burned his
house down i would still say
that he needs to pull himself together
and act like a man
but in reality she didn't do a single
damn thing to him at all remember this
man was a football player
though he never made it off the practice
squad maybe this is why
they didn't want some whiny crying wimp
in the locker room
now eventually i can report matt did
pull himself together enough
to manage to communicate in full
sentences and his message was that he's
hurt
and he's disappointed and he's not ready
to forgive
he's not ready he's so traumatized
by this picture from a frat party three
years ago he thinks about it every day
he's losing sleep over it he's tossing
and turning
at night talking to himself the frat
party picture i can't sleep
she has a lot of work to do he said
she's got a lot of work to do
he has this amoral
soulless narcissist he has no work to do
but she has a lot of work to do and he
can't do that work for her
he said she's got to do it herself then
she tried to hug him
and he turned her down as the last in
dignity
so they brought on this white woman
purely to humiliate her
and to humiliate her for being a white
woman because that is her real crime
here let's be clear
that's what she did wrong well you're
seeing what
in that picture what she's doing wrong
is having that skin tone
and yet everyone else on the stage is
the victim
not her and actually i agree with that
last part at least she's not a victim
they certainly aren't but neither is she
this is self-inflicted
she has volunteered for this position
offered herself up for it repeatedly
this is how cancel culture survives and
thrives
this is the fuel that sustains it
it needs not just people to cancel
and it's got a never-ending supply of
those and it can cancel anybody anytime
but that's not enough it needs people
who will go along with the whole
ceremony the whole charade
right for for the whole human sacrifice
it's like the aztecs when they when they
had a human sacrifice brought them up
the temple
put them down on the slab cut their
heart out held the heart up cut off
their limbs rolled their body
down the temple steps it was a whole
ceremony they had to do
and it's a kind of similar thing here
because the difference is the aztecs
would actually just put you in chains
and bring you up to them you didn't
really have a choice
here though they're not putting you in
chains you have to volunteer you have to
come out and say all right i'm here
rip my heart out
they need people who will lay down and
be carcasses for the vultures to pick
apart
and it's never gonna stop it will never
stop until we
until we all stop volunteering for that
role
until we all look at the mob and say i
don't apologize
i will never apologize i don't care how
you feel and by the way please
kiss my ass that's the only way
that's the only appropriate response
that's the only moral response
to these lunatics that's the only way
that any of this stops
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated